Platform three for the 18:20 southwest train service to Woking via Weybridge.
Calling at Vauxhall, Clapham Junction, Earlsfield, Wimbledon, Surbiton, Esher,...
...Hersham, Walton-on-Thames, Weybridge, Byfleet and New Haw, West Byfleet and Woking.
This train is formed of eight coaches.
Platform three for the 18:20 southwest train service to Woking via Weybridge.
Platform 18 for the 18:22 southwest train service to Addlestone via Hounslow.
Calling at Vauxhall, Queenstown Road Battersea, Clapham Junction,...
...Wandsworth Town, Putney, Barnes, Barnes Bridge, Chiswick, Kew Bridge,...
...Bradford, Syon Lane, Isleworth, Hounslow, Felton, Ashford Middlesex, Staines,...
....Egham, Virginia Water, Chertsey and Addlestone.
Due to short platforms, customers for Isleworth and Chertsey...
...should join the front four coaches.